[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
happy Wednesday technically the ps+ free
games from March were out yesterday but
we're gonna check them out today call of
duty modern warfare remastered as well
as the witness and I think been said
that technically Metal Gear Solid 4 is
also available but we're primarily just
gonna check out call of duty modern
warfare as well as the witness probably
about an hour or so of Call of Duty and
then about half an hour or so of the
witness I'm literally waiting eight
seconds according to this for the for
the download to finish cuz yeah it was a
pretty bit seventy five gigs we should
be good now so let's let's try this out
I haven't played modern warfare in a
long time I played a little bit of
remastered when it first came out but
this was the cod that got me into call
of duty and no no guest today primarily
because I'm actually not a hundred
percent and this is a good way to
quarantine myself off from everyone else
you know so this way you know nobody
else has to be in here getting any
sickness from you hopefully this works I
would assume the population is pretty
high because of PS Plus usually with
online games they tend to you know if
people have PS Plus then you know they
tend to play the games that are free
alright twenty five percent off a bundle
cool let's just find a game I'm probably
get wrecked after your like was played
EDM level one day one soldier here I
should be good
[Music]
all right let's 18 potential games all
right there's a lot of low level okay so
a lot of people getting in on that ps+
action 75 gigs
not 175 but still 75 is quite a bit all
right I'm gonna have to try to remember
not to slide I don't know there's gonna
be a bunch of stuff also not having a
class is gonna be pretty tough I guess
smg's good I don't know we'll see where
should we go assault I'm 16 stopping
power is pretty good we'll see how this
goes I pad feeling but we'll see all
right just setting ourselves you know
setting ourselves up for I can't man
call that Rick I want to slide so bad
all right calls Beauty game just got a
sprint our way up you know is there okay
we got we still got the dives we could
potentially dolphin dive ish also just
play real slow and camping you know I
can't remember if this is the first one
or the like a firing haven't ran into
anyone yet that's good I guess
oh it's the it's the Opie burst one all
right we good
[Music]
oh he was in the way back wasn't he
shucks aru's no mentos slide yeah I know
but I still got this I could go into the
prone and the m-16 is still a very
strong gun so you know we'll be alright
play we'll try to play a little oh hello
a little slower is what I was gonna say
and then I got picked and I don't
remember the maps either
will you play single-player oh good
maybe play a little bit alright we're
not doing terrible we're not doing great
either
you know that hot one one action one one
ratio rather YouTube in you noob tubing
man oh we hit them
just some apex legends right here what
there's no door there oh I got rekt out
of the way sir
you know what's funny it's almost st.
Patty's Day right or am I crazy I'm
pretty sure it's all the same guy
Tuesday seems relevant it's like how
much can we like headglitch where are
they coming from they're everywhere
so what caused your favorite ooh that's
tough either at probably em mm Doug
we noob tubing I don't know how I feel
about that
yeah I line them up Hair Salons we flip
them oh no choke you sure you a beat
sooner probably rubble No
don't even remember that illustrate
shocking me nope he just he just m-16 me
alright the old m16 stopping power right
all right leading our team but haven't
haven't killed someone in a while feels
bad a mistake one thing I don't miss
though is a cod spawn points they're
still some of the most
doo-doo-doo-doo s stuff it stopped right
worked out ha for the picture picture
Oh No why
no I choked
I took the double their eye lit I
actually choked that double go at least
someone shot down the chopper I remember
back in the day we'd have to be like do
someone switch check out the chopper and
it would never be me because I hated
shooting choppers down yep
just clear it man oh oh no back to 101
we're back to that 101
I went on tilt after I didn't get that
double tree oh we have something that's
not have a strike package
[Music]
SiC that had nothing
dang it alright I failed us we did not
get our asses kicked
definitely not as fluid but you know
it's a it's a remaster it still feels it
I do miss old Call of Duty alright we
ended it with one one kill ratio it's
not bad old man Harry went to work on us
I think if they didn't have that guy
we'd probably be alright
use that strike yeah I just realized I
had the strike that's my B I'm a chicken
PS store still not showing up haha well
Matt do you have give us we leveled sick
only level two though I was third
highest score right yeah that's also a
good point Keith says that if you put
the PS Plus game into your library it
will be there forever even if you don't
download it right away
so you can definitely do that so we get
out of this Lobby so that we don't get
old mand harried you guys ever do that
you ever leave a lobby because you
didn't want to deal with a certain team
what did you just always were player you
just win it back is this a winter
version of the crash map I think it is I
never played it actually should be fun I
miss I miss apex legends that's for sure
I always always be playing apex Carlo
says it's available in Croatia yeah I
should have been out as of yesterday
well old man here you left because he
was afraid of us okay we're good what
can we change about our character here
we're gonna buy these I don't remember
any of this
classic lonely teh island um I'm a
little sick goob so it has a winter
crash from AB lol yeah it's a holiday
season I guess thank you all for tuning
in to GameSpot live live Monday to
Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
today checking out
the PlayStation Plus free games in March
assuming you have PlayStation Plus as
somebody mention you don't have to
download right away just add it to the
library currently playing call of duty
modern warfare remastered are gonna play
for another 50 minutes and then we'll
swap over to the lateness I'm not really
I didn't play the witness it's a
beautiful looking game I'm not oh like
the best puzzle solver so that might be
in might be rough so I need your help
oh great great black thing on point 100%
on point what's a flashbang I don't I
don't even know dude I do not remember
this map holiday presents okay they do
turning the presents which is
interesting
do you like hiding this helicopter and
they'll never know right
come on come down Main Street
or I'll get new tubes that was deserved
though how this deserve God the time to
kill though huh
right
[Music]
Oh Santa came to deliver new - dude
someone that's high-level is probably
having themselves a ball right now
killing me oh you had last stand you
scummy man what
how is he in this corner when he's not
in this corner alright great job UAV
wonderful job you're here
there's no one gonna take that thing out
this is gonna be a rough huh huh we
can't even get rid of it alright good
luck team I can't help you out I can't
take it out fire is it gone is it over
was that dog one or end up to you the
combat knife stopping power and 16 and
op1 burst
what's like start spawning from here
dead
what's a spawning back there he was like
asking to be killed huh
we'll get um
come on yeah trickle bring it in Santa
join up oh yeah call it in baby call in
that helicopter it's our time
yeah you guys get to hide in here
okay give them another airstrike
although they're not gonna come out I
guess that was kind of always there just
chillin in the building
or we'll get a triple
[Music]
oh it's all coming back to me chat it's
all coming back that dirty air strike
into a helicopter
how did you not let me shoot bro
all right sorry sorry we got that m16
Opie Opie oh don't worry don't worry
Ryan we don't need to camp we don't need
to camp right now we're gonna ham like
riding in the bike baby like riding the
bike the old juice and gin back in the
end of seat I don't know where this
voice is coming from I apologize I mean
it's mainly the dayquil that's kind of
throwing me off
you know dayquil is a hell of a drug I
don't even think we even need to create
a class we're just gonna use that
assault class with stopping power m16
that's all we need do I have any Colin
Clark cards here I I haven't earned
anything how do I come on man I just had
a I just had a four to one all right
with this one I guess can't afford
anything we got a little like the cat a
little kitty cat well Fox what did the
Fox say can't afford any of these when
do they add this stuff is this always
been I just did not flavor mastered huh
shamrock and all the arctic wolf
we don't have any credit anyway so it is
America when the de quo got u-turns yeah
we turnt up it's alright you know what
it is it's a lot of people trying want
to warfare for the first time probably
that ps+ but like I said that one noob
tuber with last and should see himself
out I I cannot believe the what is what
are you trying to do right now
that's a cat okay oh the beach bog I
wasn't a huge fan of this map crash more
fun to me probably just because it's a
smaller map this one's kind of bigger
got that middle where like the tanks and
stuff are is a lot of buildings a lot of
verticality I think that last match is
the best match we're gonna have today
it's like beach no this is so weird
oh he's new to be slow on my 80s so what
I get
there's so many of them they're all like
in this one alley
I saw you but now I don't see you I'm so
screwed all right good job team oh my
god save me I don't remember this map
being this way
[Music]
oh my god please airstrike that like
they're all in a freaking row screwed
three flashbangs later so how's everyone
doing attack cuz I can't see anything
so-called will crawl our way to success
okay
well this map is basically like how
often can I get flashbacks right
[Music]
I play like you do huh
actual duty
yep
already I've done nothing
someone must have this absolute
[Music]
I don't know what the heck that was it
was like that one guy was like feeling
miserable I guess nice shot nice shot
that's what we should be doing head
glitching
they all get inside uh it's not coming
back to me I lied to you all see if we
can save our Katie here Oh No
oh let's not all be here please you're
about to get like one grenade
[Applause]
yeah we got the final kill though I
didn't really do anything do do baby big
boo-boo steam oh no got that well look
that's us with our little cat oh we
saved it we saved it
we had one guy literally go ham 7kt
well got put in the backpack well we can
make this class now finally oh no we got
out we gotta unlock challenges huh
they're always only two perks on those
three perks
try this snap it's not gonna be a good
look can I get perk number one here
oh there you go
c4x to special needs x3 RPG x2 oh now
we're trying to woo bacon sure probably
just did the triple special grenade or
something
much deem death much that's true
actually we had it on the Xbox and I
don't remember this map totally looks
like we got a killer boys mp5
yikes
in mp5 right now
here we'll try the MP oh I wasn't tried
the MP by surprise
what big key word was good shotgun there
we got we got sweat ease
we got actual sweat ease right now one
to your left
I got outplayed the memories yep even
died from the first burst
might not be that shotgun though
yup yup yup yup feels bad man
step it up Oh so far back that you don't
lose your leg yeah yeah that's a watch
playing like old man Tate well you know
first bad game clearly there were guys
that have been playing you can just tell
that's all right
how goes yeah their whole team over 1 KD
only one of our guys was even one KD
sounds about right
let's see you
what's classic very classic old-school
free-for-all I don't know if I'm good
enough for that
he did kill confirmed Susan Kill
Confirmed you overgrown big map
fun times definitely bringing me back
gotta get up there man that brings me
back to you we're one off the coast reef
guess we should have camped it
how do you get all the way over there
ready all right it wasn't it wasn't in
vain sometimes you could bake the tag
though I suppose never been one to do
that though I know people that do it oh
hello
happy birthday they're right in front of
you sniper be careful
[Music]
[Music]
Oh pick those tags up eat them all up
can I get a UAV for that it's all
killstreak based on it's not like
destiny where everything adds up all
right it's okay we got the helicopter
yeah but where's mine where's my strike
strike though
yes right
oh come on helicopter avenge me yeah get
on helicopter you're staying in the
houses this is probably the one map that
the helicopter is not as good because of
the houses but it's okay
get out the way there's another guy here
just give up
I'll get your tag
I didn't I thought for sure all right
good recovery game they're very no Devil
May Cry 5 today we can't stream it yet
tomorrow though Red Hulk I believe is
when we can be pop credit [ __ ] that
whoa whoa language language sir
where are my killstreaks nope don't want
to be in here I'll have a supply no cool
yeah equip it I don't even know where
those came from but all right
where be my killstreaks well oh well
sippin that win juice yeah uh-oh
crossfire um chat help me where where is
my killstreaks you don't get to use your
killstreaks if you don't use it right
away oh really oh sorry I had to use it
first okay okay all right that's good to
know he go Tommy thank you I got you use
the killstreak sooner I guess is what it
sounds like it's weird that I can't
change it though
okay chopper gunner on don't remember
this man bring in a die horrible death
could already sense the danger but I was
committed to getting that tag Wow you
lamb Peron huh you're a sneaky sneaky
man Oh like that night yeah the whole
team was that up
maybe I sing too slow how did I get a
kill
all right at least I got that guy before
that noob - sure got this guy that new
perceived me though
you see nothing we gotta get these tags
oh how is that guy behind us that's not
good dude turn turns around my friends
[Music]
I not okay
surprisingly the game is closed
considering how much we're getting
I saw him too late I get this tag a
helicopter didn't do its job Oh
helicopter
oh my please
single shot thank you we've built that
guys alright that you can kill him
right back on the other side
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
bring the airstrike all the way
did it for the helicopter come on give
me the helicopter why is it not
available I'd like to exit this bus
sorry if I got super quiet there is like
[Music]
live in the zone alright that's a good
run that's good run oh they shot my
helicopter down
[Music]
why would you do that that was not very
nice that's not a street to go down
on the copter down Blackhawk down
Blackhawk down I'll go for his hag pick
up the tags oh gee golly whiz wow I was
so sure he was dead that's why you like
stop dating
if we lose this on the side
another way at least you can deny it I
guess
[Music]
ah no team came do you even l2 when I
need to that was me too that died
awesome yeah what what do you want me to
do I have 47 Gil's screenshot that I had
47 kills what what more can I do for the
team what could I possibly have done
chat help me oh man
I wasn't confirming enough you know what
that's what it was I wasn't killed
confirming enough that's what it was I
needed to confirm more kills 100% you
know now that I think about it that's
where I failed that is 100% where Vale
should've had 50 yeah I guess so
I probably would have doubt dad probably
would have saved us play the witness
soon last match and then witness
it's a remorse it's called duty modern
warfare remastered and then the witness
which we'll get into here in a second oh
there's only six people back it out
there we'll just do TDM oops okay cool
we're in TDM we're just gonna do TDM
it's faster and we're playing non winter
crash Auto mutant if you haven't been
around PlayStation now is basically
sponsoring GameSpot live for a whole
month
basically you'll see this picture and
picture for a couple more weeks and then
also we have one more big PlayStation
now stream that's gonna be blood-borne
it's gonna be me and John Luke it should
be a fun one blood-borne is always a fun
time where's Ben tonight Ben is busy I
asked but he's busy unfortunately
Socrates alright last match let's hope
that I can play a good one
we'll see I think we did pretty well
last time on crash but it's kind of
threw me off with all the Christmas
holiday stuff the like ho ho ho air
strikes and the people exploding into
gifts that's kind of like actual like
presents not gifts like
we think they're going I guess I'll try
to go this way we could try to just get
high ground and hope that no one knows
pushing a lot this would be a good spot
if there is one if I could hit something
damn no one's coming huh
come on you want to know did our boys
get them
you Adam with me right now on the real
I'll play like this anymore
try boring watch
but it is kind of what you'd used to do
back in the day we're gonna spawn back
here what I used to do
Oh someone got to our spot finally good
for him proud of him call duty spawns am
i right
am i right ladies and gentlemen let's
see if you think he has like c4 might be
able to just get him from o4 you guess
he doesn't want to peek out though I
know he's looking at this way maybe good
night
right there I got outplayed that guy
that guy's legit right there he's a pro
no Intel certain quality players I don't
have them reactions anymore to do that
back in the day
Luke did dude
they don't come back possibly feel like
the guys like so many players
[Music]
you saw that guy right
oh no our killstreak Luke the Duke
walls really hard to see over especially
with the iron sights
I'm bad we already got 75 kills with the
m16 pretty good good alright why are you
playing this game ask Cameron because
it's a one of the two free ps4 titles or
part PS plus in March of 2019 actually
works out right on time twelve O'Clock
3.29 Katie not bad so let's uh quickly
hop over and play some witness here cuz
there's a second game this month I'll be
honest I might struggle here so I might
need your help um but I think the early
puzzle shouldn't be too bad but I never
played the witness so this could be a
good time to do that if you want to try
it just at least add it to your library
as somebody I mentioned earlier if you
add it to your library it's always there
you can download it or whenever as long
as you get it before the game's kind of
like once they disappear but they're off
of the free games for the month alright
okay I have to go forward can't look
back probably the opening scene here to
the beautiful world of the witness
so I think like all right we did it we
solved the puzzle okay
all right like how it's it's teaching us
mechanics here and they get way more
complex I know that and you can kind of
go wherever you want but some puzzles
and things are definitely harder than
others this is just such a calming
experience after all that murdering we
just did you know like what is this like
how do I even all right let's see I
gotta get to the end so it's like a maze
do I have to get to the end though okay
so that helped us get power just
something this door oh there's three
more power switch is it looks like that
we need got one two three take a look
soak it all in here
this one looks pretty straightforward
just compared to the last one and then
it looks like a third one over here that
is not on okay I got to do this one to
transfer power over there okay what are
we trying to get you though on this one
okay here's our hint okay so that guy
should be on now
nope that's wrong wait how do we get
there
that doesn't make sense we can't get
there from here right we can't get there
nope that's wrong Oh
I had a derp moment there a real derp
moment there's also environmental
puzzles if you stay under a specific
yeah I I kind of know about that too but
we'll see what we can do I'm gonna try
my best probably won't stick on puzzles
too long if I'm gonna get stuff out
there's one more switch we gotta get
here just wanna sit here and enjoy the
scenery but we gotta do possible so on
that side here corner okay
either one is fine
huh
I'm not seeing it
Fareway there it is
does that mean the bottom one is also
solvable
where are your thoughts on Modern
Warfare remaster I think it's a fun game
I like modern warfare was one of my oh
there's another have to use this again
water warfare was one of probably my one
of my favorite games growing up as a
multiplayer shooter I think my friend
had it on Xbox 360 the first time when I
first played it and we would just swap
back and forth the controller you know
depending on dirt in between matches so
that the other person could play that
was kind of how you did it back in the
day nowadays I feel like everyone has a
console what am I missing here it's
crazy how I even got to where I did just
now because I can't even see it anymore
okay we reverse engineer
we basically gotta go the same way we
just win which I just spaced on how we
got there boy
yes it's this way this way and this
alright okay okay oh that turned on
different things huh okay well I'm
pretty sure we needed to turn this one
on so hopefully that was right part of
me
okay I think we got this door open
hopefully curious what that other puzzle
was out out the other way though am i
starting from here
guessing that point doesn't matter
should we turn this one back on the
other way yeah
let's just go I don't want it to like
close up again okay cool so now we can
run even though you know ok so here's
like a puzzle
oh is this a puzzle - oh boy
what is the black dots mean though okay
what's wrong can I only touch one black
dot is that what that means okay maybe
we can't do this one yet
oh you know what it is maybe maybe we
have to get every black dot all right
let's try that although this wouldn't
this snake into itself yeah cuz how
would we go back up right cuz we can't
sneak into ourselves so that's not right
I don't think what I just did was
correct all right come back to you later
we'll come back to you later we'll come
back to you I hear you have two separate
black and white with the line sorry
we'll try another puzzle you know we
feel that one puzzle there's plenty more
puzzles to try all right let's see if
this one will help me learn about this
next one okay wants me to touch the red
one too so guessing in this case it's
get both black dots alright moving on to
the next puzzle I got to get all the
dots again can't go that way
okay
crime says a 100% of this so ask me
anything
gotcha thank you uh we'll see I mean
like once we get really stuck on a
puzzle that's when I probably will ask
for some assistance can't do that right
cuz we can't go up and around
no feels like we have to go this way
first
nailed it
sometimes you take a second takes a
second sorry like I said I'm just okay
at puzzle games so can you start at
either one that way
[Music]
does make you feel smart when you figure
it out
work
don't work either oh there's a dot over
there I think this drew before doing it
okay let's see
down let's see if we go this way
okay what do we unlock from that sound
likely I'm out the door or something
thought I heard a door so we probably
get between the black and the white
right every time like this
I don't think this is right this is
wrong yeah okay those two we didn't cut
across I can't do that
I wish circle would let you just okay
doesn't cancel can't go that way this
way first
does that count because I'm cutting
across all of it No
can't do that
just a white
okay do we try this I feel like we tried
this one already right you know think
this didn't work yeah
I feel like we tried this - and it
didn't work
just go around the white one oh are you
guys talking about the last one
that's definitely wrong and we tried
this way where we sneaked try this yeah
right up right up later Otto you can go
to sleep no separate
you were killing me yeah I told you this
was gonna happen
you just didn't believe me right trial
and error I don't understand why that
one worked but okay okay so we're
separating the whites and the blacks
that's not doing it is that working
no so what if we know this isn't gonna
work either though I don't think oh of
course it worked okay
oh I'm sorry I think I think I get it I
think I get it okay all right
I'm sorry chat forgive me I now
understand I had the moment okay
no no how do we get that guy though how
do we save that guy from the rest of
this because we can't do that and doing
that it's not gonna work
right unless we do this there you go all
right we're getting there there it is
the Oh moment yeah yeah she's got a box
ease off oh [ __ ] okay let's go the other
way
nailed it we're so smart we have evolved
have we evolved we'll see we have not
evolved we have not evolved okay no we
have evolved we have evolved what did I
do
what did I get for that do we unlock
something oh so can we do this other
puzzle now that I understand now that I
maybe understand a little bit more am i
separated so this is all black right now
right oh this is way more complex than
the last couple that we've done I don't
know if I'm ready for this yet yeah all
right no we're coming back I'm sorry
that one's a little little much for me
right now I've got some puzzles finish
I saw another like singing here a little
console all right now we're looking at
trees just one Apple was the one Apple
represent what like any of them
no is it the one with the am I looking
at the twigs right there and I'm getting
to the Apple right so is this the Apple
yeah okay that's the Apple all right so
let's follow where that okay the Apple
is in the middle oh that's not even a
great it's not a great visual there I'm
gonna guess okay
wait what oh no is this one of those you
gotta get them all right situations no
the help what happened to my power
okay
okay let's take a look so we're looking
at it like this there's one two it's a
it's the fourth branch which would be
the last one I'm so confused right now 1
4 2 4 3 4 it's the fourth fork on the
left 1 4 2 4 3 4 ok so one on that left
ok ok
oh no no no alright there's that Apple
and we still have one by itself
yeah ok then 1 2 it's the fourth one and
on the right so 1 2 3 4 fourth one on
the right
then we're going over here wherever here
is
okay hours
that's not resembling where's the one
twig on its own cuz that's a - that's a
- and that's right can we work the other
way is this now reversed because here's
like a one twig there's two twig one
twig to twig one twig or it started to
tweak - twig so - one two - so it's the
next one to the left I think I hope
fudge okay I'm so used to Call of Duty
jumping right now dang it now I got to
figure this one out again I think wait
which one was it
cuz of this one and it goes to this one
why would it make you repeat it if you
already have the answer
that came son that seems kind of silly
unless it was gonna force you to do it
again yeah okay
so what I'm not sure about is that
there's the one twig right so it's like
two twig into this one twig into a two
twig to twig so technically it should
have been Oh dad I pick the one on the
left or the right it should have been
okay didn't did did I not do it this way
is this way right
isn't it this one right like cuz okay
cuz there's a two twig branch and
there's the one twig so it's like
reversed right so because there's no
like if we're looking left to right it's
not act oh you know what it is it's the
perspective thing isn't it it's probably
this way so one two three four and then
the fifth one so I picked the one on the
left and it didn't you did it right not
this one though
yeah because is it not this one because
we know that it's I'm so confused right
now change your perspective over here I
mean like unless it's the one on the
right I guess okay since we tried the
left they're the only other option is to
go to this one yeah so I'm guessing it
was I said it was flipped what it was
supposed to be looking at it like this I
guess
but even then this would oh yeah okay
it's the one on the right shirt okay
whatever sure okay so now this one is
one branch one two three then another
one branch yep then one one
yes I agree I'm definitely better at
shooting than I am where is this other
tree I'm clearly looking at the right
tree right clearly have they all been
green trees they've all been green geez
okay so this tree where the hell is the
Apple
there is no Apple all right let's just
at least get our perspective right so
there's the 2 and the 1 and then a 2 and
a 1 and then there's a 2 shouldn't that
be a to no one because that this branch
is correct the long one with the fork
here and this one's wrong so is it the
one that's wrong
all right it was the one that was wrong
why are you throwing Metta at me you're
breaking the rules of your own puzzles
an apple slice where did that that
ultimately lead to was that just to
leave me to these apples and hearts
apples and hearts do we finish another
one cuz I know I guess it opened this
doorway right oh you soon
all right oh wait there's more power
where's that power that considered power
okay I'm guessing we can't yeah it's not
gonna let us drop down I don't know
where that goes to anyways moving on to
the next
let's go up here oh we got time for like
one more puzzle I guess alright we
finished the Apple ones right so this
windmill have something oh boy ok this
time I feel like we're supposed to just
like pac-man this thing right yeah get
pac-man no that's not gonna work oh this
way tell me where to go what about the
other side can I only do one side of
power right now what if I
yeah okay the job will unlock nope it's
not it what did that do what the heck
did that do I can't tell it doesn't look
like you did anything all right let's
try one more puzzle what are we looking
at the one grey cloud maybe all right
let's take a look at this one blue boy
all right this is probably wrong okay
this one of those sectioning them off
again kind of things
oh wait yeah we could cleanly section it
off sort of nope
all right there's always a hint right
some sort what about this one you're
like how fickle I am holy crap colors
colors red white and blue is that even a
thing No
damn come on red white and blue is on
one side this is an advanced puzzle
section yeah okay moving on somewhere
else then you will not get in until
later so the tetris blocks one okay
let's try finding another area where we
can maybe do something more my my level
you know is awesome
do that is pretty dope is this another
one of those really hard ones [ __ ] try
in my head it's like I've walled off the
black but that is probably incorrect all
right clearly I don't think I'm supposed
to be here either
so let's go back over here
their paths pass away it's nice
can't walk in the water sadly world
puzzle the desert oh maybe we can do a
puzzle next to the apples that we just
did
maybe oh boy
I'm guessing I can't do this puzzle yet
two yellow dots maybe you have to form
two blocks shape with your line form
that's too much right now I wanted to
just do one more puzzle of my level but
I don't know as in like my personal
levels my personal skill let's see if
okay oh okay I think it's supposed to
match the thing on the other side oh
okay just one of those I thought it was
like looking into that thing okay we
don't have power for that mean power so
it starts over here okay
I was like the first puzzle turn
[Music]
all right this is more this is more of
where I'm at except it feels really
awkward to like
it's like opposite it's really throwing
me all my days what is this
what's the difference between doing that
and the outside one can't do that yet no
power I'm mildly cookies I guess that's
where we end all right I'm content I
finished one more puzzle that's pretty
cool for me anyways thanks for tuning in
if you want to and you have PlayStation
Plus make sure to add call of duty
modern warfare remastered to your
library and the witness and Metal Gear
Solid 4 because that gives you the
ability to download it whenever you want
just make sure you do it before the end
of the month or before the end of the
cycle essentially but until next time
come back tomorrow I'm pretty sure
you'll have something fun to watch we
might even have two streams tomorrow but
don't hold me to it there's definitely
gonna be one though so until then peace
out